many of your favorite marvel movies
feature plenty of intense action
sequences
plenty of which required your favorite
superhero stars to get out of their
comfort zones in fact there's been more
than a couple of times when filming
these scenes got so extreme that it
actually became quite dangerous for
everyone involved yes
that was awesome tom holland felt like
the right decision was made when filming
spider-man's first encounter with the
villainous vulture in homecoming ending
with spidey being dropped in a lake
holland had initially begged the crew to
allow him to perform the stunt in the
end a stuntman was flown out in a
helicopter and then was dunked in the
lake in the most dangerous stunt of the
film after watching it play out holland
was thankful that he didn't end up doing
it claiming that watching the stuntman
perform the dive was the scariest thing
he had ever seen zoe zeldana typically
enjoys a lot of her own stunt work
whenever she has the opportunity to but
that doesn't make it any less
frightening at times saldana was
required to jump from around 30 feet off
the ground and while wire work was being
used she forgot that the jump was going
to feel much more like a free fall so
when they said action and i jumped cause
obviously i don't like to take my time
because there's so many men watching you
i jumped and thought i was dying james
gunn wasn't really a fan of saldana's
acting in that scene and made her
perform the jump again just give me your
face on that camera you got it
while filming the comedy tag hawkeye
himself jeremy renner injured himself
and wound up with two broken arms renner
had to film end game directly after
rapping tag which meant that his arms
hadn't fully recovered this led to it
being excruciatingly painful for renner
to perform his archery scenes as hawkeye
renner had even attempted to go to
physical therapy but ultimately ended up
bearing through the pain renner realized
that hawkeye really wouldn't be hawkeye
without his bow and arrow now that's
commitment to the character
while filming t'challa in claws fight
scene in seoul south korea the late
chadwick boseman had a hard time seeing
out of his mask this was even more
unfortunate for andy serkis who just
expected a normal fight scene but wasn't
prepared for bozeman to be totally
committed to the role bozeman ended up
accidentally kneeing circus in the chest
so hard in the first take that he
thought his ribs were broken on top of
that the same scene would then be shot
30 more times
king
one of the most dangerous scenes bobby
holland hampton had to film as a double
was when he was standing in for evans in
age of ultron during the car chase
sequence in seoul the scene required him
to literally surf on a door through the
streets of the south korean city one
false move would have led him not to be
able to double for hemsworth just a few
weeks later well he's definitely unhappy
though the most dangerous stunt robert
downey jr's double glenn foster ever
performed was when filming the climactic
construction site battle in iron man 3.
the scene was actually shot at night
making the stunts even more dangerous
and required foster to jump off cranes
that were around three to four hundred
feet high you're leaping into darkness
and trusting that the various cables
you're attached to are going to do what
they're supposed to
one of the most exhilarating scenes to
film in ant-man in the wasp was filming
a stunt during the film's car chase
sequence the stunt required stunt woman
ingrid klenig to stand on the back of a
flatbed truck as a van would rear-end it
this caused kleneg to fly through the
back of the truck and smash through the
van's glass windshield all in the hot
and fast streets of atlanta
the opening action sequence in the first
episode of the falcon and the winter
soldier featured one of the most
dangerous stunts in the mcu to date with
the plane hijacking ninety percent of
the impressive set piece was done
practically with the red bull air force
and a group of experienced wingsuit
pilots assisted on the scene as well
they were flying at 140 miles an hour
and only a mere six inches off from each
other as the scene needed them to be as
precise as possible literally the
world's best wingsuit flyers who are
ready to do this stuff for us during
spider-man's fight scene with captain
america cap ends up backhanding him with
his shield a ratchet and wire would pull
stuntman marvin ross forward which would
activate a dead man line attached to his
back this meant whenever somebody would
hit him he would get slammed to the
ground and just after the first take
ross felt like he couldn't move we end
up doing it four or five times and after
those sequences i was trying to drink
and i couldn't even taste anything my
mind's not blown
his might be as well chris pratt had
always been curious about performing
some of star-lord stunts himself but he
didn't know just how dangerous they
could be while performing a stunt that
had him and a stunt performer suspended
15 feet in the air the plans were for
pratt and the double to fall to the
ground with controlled speed ultimately
landing on a mat unfortunately things
didn't go as planned as the crew
accidentally thrust pratt down in double
the speed pratt tried to get in a
position that wouldn't hurt the stuntman
but it did make for quite the hard
landing i turned this way and bounced my
face off the mat i saw a flash of yellow
and it tasted like smoke in my mouth you
know what i'm talking about while
filming the scene in the fifth episode
of the limited series where sam and
bucky were trying to fix the wilson's
family boat sebastian stan was required
to jump from a dock and onto the boat i
just landed and twisted my ankle so
badly that i thought it was broken like
i actually couldn't walk on it
daniel hargrave served as chris evans
stunt double in multiple mcu outings but
one of his craziest experiences
performing dangerous stunts came while
filming the wakanda battle in avengers
infinity war a wire was attached to
hargrave's chest to make it look as if
he was running much faster pargrave made
a misstep which caused him to trip i
couldn't keep up with the winch so i
fell and got dragged face first for
about 20 yards passing by all these
superheroes
it's not gonna happen bobby holland
hanton suffered quite a mighty blow
while performing a risky stunt as thor
in infinity war after being smacked off
his feet by peter dinklage's e-tree
hanton was punted off the ground while
somersaulting through the air and
ultimately landing face first on a rock
and then head planting into the ground
while it may sound painful to hampton
the danger is all part of the job trust
me i know
george kirby had quite the explosive job
cut out for him while doubling for
benedict cumberbatch in doctor strange
in the scene where kisilius attacks the
sanctum sanctorum kirby's assistance was
required for a more rugged stunt as an
exploding spell is cast a contraption
consisting of a piston and wires would
hoist him back extremely fast causing
him to fly upside down through the air
while chris pratt's star-lord mask has a
built-in fan and vent to make it
breathable his stunt double chris
ramrell didn't have that same privilege
the mask became increasingly difficult
for ramrell to see out of and after a
while it became more of a liability
while performing an action scene in
infinity war that required him to
perform a backflip he hit the back of
his head which caused the mask to
shatter off his face but thankfully ron
rell wasn't hurt
the cast and crew behind the marvel
films have proven to be extremely
committed to giving fans some killer
action scenes even some of the biggest
stars like to take part in their own
stunt work like tom holland and
sebastian stan what's your favorite
marvel action scene
you